getting down to toddler height
and looking up at the great big world through their tiny little eyes,
taking these seemingly complex ideas and simplifying them --
not dumbing them down,
but homing in on the core concept.
Gender is about how we feel and how we express ourselves.
Sexuality is about love and gender and family,
not about sex.
And these are all ideas children can grasp.
In one of my earliest episodes about gender,
I used the idea of pronouns
to underscore the definition and introduce gender-neutral pronouns
like "they" and "them."
I encourage children to think about their own pronouns
and to ask others for theirs.
In later episodes, I build on this foundation
and introduce big fancy words like "nonbinary" and "transgender."
I get emails from viewers in their 20s
who use my videos to explain nonbinary gender to their grandparents.
But, I get one comment over and over again:
"Let kids be kids."
Well, that's a nice sentiment and all,
but only if it actually includes all kids.
Just a few weeks ago,
a 15-year-old in Huntsville, Alabama
died by suicide after being bullied for being gay.
In 2018, it was a seven-year-old
in Denver, Colorado.
There have been and will be many more.
Lesbian, gay and bisexual teens
are more than three times more likely to attempt suicide
than their heterosexual peers,
and transgender teens are almost six times more likely.
According to one study, roughly one third of homeless youth
identify as lesbian, gay, bisexual or questioning,
and about four percent of homeless youth identify as transgender,
compared with one percent of the general youth population surveyed.
According to the Human Rights Campaign,
there have been 128 killings of trans people
in 87 cities across 32 states
since 2013.
And those are the only the reported cases.
And 80 percent of those killings were of trans women of color.
The queer situation is bleak,
to say the least.
The YouTube comments on my videos
are not much better.
I'm used to the harassment.
I get messages daily telling me I'm a pedophile
and that I should kill myself in a number of increasingly creative ways.
I once had to put the word "truck" on my block list
because someone wanted me to get run over by a truck.
"Shower" and "oven" are in there, too,
for the less creative and more disturbing Holocaust reference.
When neo-Nazis marched in Charlottesville,
I was unsurprised to learn
that the creator of a violent Reddit meme about one of my episodes
was in the tiki torch crowd.
This barrage of negativity is what we're up against:
the crushing statistics, the violence, the mental health risks,
the well-meaning but flawed response my parents gave me when I came out,
that they didn't want me to have a harder life.
That's what we're up against.
But in the face of all that,
I choose joy.
I choose rainbows and unicorns and glitter,
and I sing that it's OK to be gay with my childhood stuffed teddy bear.
I make queer media for kids
because I wish I had this when I was their age.
I make it so others don't have to struggle through what I did,
not understanding my identity
because I didn't have any exposure to who I could be.
I teach and spread this message through joy and positivity
instead of framing it around the hardships of queer life.
I want kids to grow up and into themselves
with pride for who they are and who they can be,
no matter who they love or what they wear or what pronouns they use.
And I want them to love others for their differences,
not in spite of them.
I think fostering this pride and empathy
will make the world a kinder and more equal place
and combat the bigotry and hate that festers in our world.
So, talk to a kid about gender.
Talk to a kid about sexuality.
Teach them about consent.
Tell them it is OK for boys to wear dresses
and for girls to speak up.
Let's spread radical queer joy.
Thank you.
(Applause)